[Applause]
like just talking [ __ ] i'm like no
that's not gonna work
so he's like i mean you buy so he
thought i've been bisexual this whole
entire time we've been dating
you're not bisexual you mean [ __ ] but
just because i let a girl eat me i don't
mean so there's a thing called the
kinsley scale and it basically shows you
right right kinsey
your own element yo well anyway
i don't know sexuality through hello
there's a movie about it and like you
can you can actually switch day to day
no because i'm gay so like maybe the day
you ate [ __ ] you was high up on that
[ __ ]
i didn't eat [ __ ] though i let her like
i'm definitely the
receiver like you're less gay yeah what
is it
uh just look up the movie it's starting
ralph famous yeah i think it's kinsey
whatever
bro um i just wanted to know what you
thought was bisexual because he swears
because if i let a girl eat me out
then i think bisexual means you have
experiences with both
right so i don't it wasn't like i
wouldn't
necessarily say you're hetero if you've
done things like that right
legs
your sexuality is different from your
emotional connection so your bisexuality
can maybe
just be talking about but if a girl eats
you out you are great
[Laughter]
i mean what kind like
i thought you were just saying i'm easy
that's what she
i think you're straight i think you got
caught up in all this hoopla
who blows a [ __ ] what is that
no what hoopla it's hoopla yeah that's
hoopla with all this like
yeah okay
people problematic but you [ __ ] with
shows i'm like damn look at him right
now
hoopla anti-shunts hoopla
that's hoopla yeah don't listen none of
that
same with all the you know
[Laughter]
because you're bisexual right yes yeah
wheezy's gay yo
bisexual because you also think
you liked him he was just gay about it
bro look at mike pence he got a wife and
[ __ ] he's gay yeah
a lot of gay dudes out there got wives
you got kids i mean i'm
bisexual you guys have sex but like
romantically i think it just depends
what would i what are you gay
be honest you're gay be honest you're
gay look at your jacket
this is a game it kind of you know i
threw the heels on because i felt like
it was too lesbian
i was just saying you're gay right i was
like nah let me sex it up
no i swear to you i thought wheezy gays
[ __ ] when i saw that jacket i really did
i was i guess
yeah i think you're a young man
but you're not ready to go she's young
yeah
no she's called me young
not that that kind of energy that energy
you know though
basically you're gonna rock the [ __ ] out
there
that energy why are you hating on
gabriel relatives
be a little bit more open-minded maybe
i'm gayer than i think yesterday we went
to philly to see his friends i was like
yo like
are any of your friends cute or should i
dress like i normally dress he's like
not a married
and so i dressed gay let me ask you this
what if you're
gay 100 percent gay mm-hmm
well i definitely love dick so that's
not a but the truth loving dick is a is
a function of friction
you're so narrow-minded about sexuality
you were used to dildos no i didn't like
that thank you
i scissored more i don't really i don't
really like toys in any realm that often
like a dick is a twist
my ex-girlfriend who was mainly like
scissors you said you had an
ex-girlfriend
hold up hold up hold up hold up hold up
mad crosstalk one question
scissoring cut that [ __ ] out
no but like what's the deal with that
like stop it y'all trying to act like
that does anything
what is this no that [ __ ] is lit bro
it's the [ __ ] to clinch yeah
that [ __ ] is hot but you know there's
way more decks
and maybe that's the issue with y'all
and why i had to teach
some of your [ __ ] army how to eat
[ __ ] the last time i don't talk about
the guy that [ __ ] you and you couldn't
take his dick like that don't make it
last yeah
it's just short cervix having that
barely sit on that seat
i got a short ass cervix i'm a fan of
scissoring
like i think it's super hot but
eventually when you say all right let's
do something real like when do you stop
scissing
well most women have clitoral orgasms
but actually
that's a lot of money that's like the
prostate i'm not lost then that's the
prostate that's
you gotta go deep
it's the kid i'll be there deep i put my
head in my shoulders because it's more
dick comes out when i go down right now
i got a little turtle you just look like
a little like uncircumcised dick popping
how does that but i go like this i give
you i put some neck in my dick
[Laughter]
that's what i do i literally transfer it
that's what i do
adam's apple adam's apple yeah yeah you
just swallow and that [ __ ]
boom ready to go viral there you go
but no in all seriousness instagram
story and i was like what is going on
i'm street certified bro
this is what it is look point is this
you're certified gay
okay 100 the jacket is rainbow i just
realized that of course it is
taylor bye but here's the thing i love
your gayness thank you so much we accept
you for who you are
we accept you for who you are we just
want you to be able to accept that
you could still like guys okay but you
can't
i have a question yeah if you get
married to a
girl then are you gay or if you get
married to a guy are you straight now
it depends i feel like you should ask
andrew this question your marital status
has nothing to do with your
sexual orientation there's a lot of
married men there can you let andrew
talk about this i mean
yeah she brought up an interesting point
but i'm curious to know what he
also it looked like stop silencing
straight men
yeah white men at that
[Laughter]
if i marry a guy i am gay okay
if i marry a girl i am not gay
what's that called normal
oh my god listen i have a lot of gay
male friends that [ __ ] a lot of
strangers true that [ __ ] is so so i'm
sorry
friend who would only only [ __ ]
straight dude and that's because there's
a lot of these dudes out there
they like they like the takedown they're
like on the gay side i get it but i
think the straight guys i think that
they're terrified
of their own homosexuality yeah and
locate that [ __ ] as [ __ ]
that [ __ ] makes me real sad because i
want i don't know like if if that's who
you love if that's who you want to be
with
right be with them you have one [ __ ]
life you might as well spend some time
with those people and that's what we're
trying to say to you
yo if you're gay you know what i mean
like what makes you
stop it for the times that we've hung
out have been around
each other yeah who does it seem like
i'm well you hit on my girl
an awful lot if i may say so myself hey
yo she's
hey yo look how gay you finish up look
how gay you finna sound
when i got the magnet for your wedding i
felt bad i was like
yeah you know yeah so because your
people just got the right to get married
no that's your man brought a bad feeling
that [ __ ] was
true that was a little traumatic what
we're trying to say is
we love you and we want you to be able
to be you
and you always have a safe environment
on this podcast to be that i think we've
shown that today you're
safe here you're safe here you're safe
here to you know
tell black women what to do you know
what i mean whatever you want to do
that's yo taylor
you're not gay yo thank you but you are
if you want to be
and we accept both of those options we
love you what a welcoming
getting your [ __ ] lick doesn't
necessarily make you gay no it doesn't
but it does make people go oh
the sizzy gladiator bro that's what she
is
she's a what the sizzy gladiator like a
scissor
yeah you're not the glizzy gladiator i
got you taylor
why'd you look at me like that i'm
trying to make sense of what mark just
did
this [ __ ] like scissors we know this in
our community
do we have a community yeah we have
white people
is mark gay i mean
he got beliage in his hair yeah that's
gay there's a lot of evidence on both
sides that [ __ ] is the your jacket of
dudes
you're like really sporting the
williamsburg look right now and the gay
ones have like a tote bag normally with
them i don't have a tote bag
so that kind of like knocks you out of
here but i do love my own dick
that's true have you ever tried to suck
it no
really i thought all guys did that like
in high school i tried to see if i could
i
wasn't gonna do it what if you could
have fit in your mouth i wanted to know
if i could it's like a stretch test
yeah it was more of that it was more
just stretching yeah i would have tried
but
i'm trying to stretch my dick into my
lips yeah inches bro
inches your boy got injured
yeah yeah out here i don't know if
you're gonna cut this out
but when i was in tulum a girl was like
yo you know andrew and she told me that
she slept with you
oh [ __ ] hold on
her name later and she was like he was
really good in bed and i said
really now you can keep this in yeah
i can't see it she was like yeah he was
i was like andrew's a goofy [ __ ]
are you
sure amazing in bed i was shocked
amazing
so you guys have some type of scorpions
say what no we're not doing fetishes no
more that's another thing
i like feet well andrew had a
conversation with me about someone he
was dating the first thing he brought up
talking about our feet you've done that
a few times
like that time we were in that diner so
about our feet bringing the foot forward
but the feet i was like why are you
shaming you know you can't just happen
oh i enjoy it but i think that shows you
that someone might be a good [ __ ] when
you know they got like some weird nasty
[ __ ] you're like oh you're disgusting
this could be good
was that girl was that girl cute the one
in in uh mexico yeah she's pretty i'll
show
see if you remember [ __ ] what i do
bro taking down
bodies out here i thought your type like
for a while
when you were single i just remembered
the girls
out of pockets
don't remember i honestly the weird
thing happened like once i fell in love
with my fiance
[Laughter]
i forgot all women bro yeah okay i
literally forgot you know what's
happened i was with my fiance
i was with my fiance i loved very much
the other day when we're walking down
the street
and i mistook this one girl uh that was
outside our building for another girl
that was in our building
right i thought they were the same
person and she was like they're not the
same and i was like man you know all
these
all these hoes look the same
except you what
you called your wife behold loki
[Laughter]
that horrible ass story i'm sorry guys
hey everybody who listened and
everybody's watching at home
i apologize for wasting your time
that's all on me that's a hundred
percent on me
sometimes you think you know where
you're going and then you like now i got
lost on the way
bro i started at the end when i knew
there wasn't a lot of real estate left
you know in a movie like when they're
driving towards the cliff and they got
to figure out a way to stop the car
there was no brakes cut the brakes the
brakes were cut
so your boy went off
point is we appreciate the attempt i
went for it
i was trying to compliment her and say
you're the only girl that i recognize
now
um that's sweet that's what i do and a
lie but we'll take it
should you gas up if a girl said that
[ __ ] to you you'd probably like it
yeah i probably would i love some
emotional [ __ ]
do girls get like super romantic with
each other
it depends what role right yeah of
course it bends with girl but if i'm
super over the top like men would assume
but it's just
i see that women that i've dated have
more empathy for [ __ ] like
for example probably haven't i will
never forget this [ __ ] i was
going through a breakup like full on
tears calling alex like
which
yo go on instagram son stop [ __ ]
crying go on instagram
go find a blue check why you acting like
this and i'm like yo
walk it off son yeah she's awesome she
couldn't walk
why do you think we went to woe hop bro
she was trying to find dicks that fit
my god yo that's [ __ ] up for you to
take us there while you're dating him
what do you mean i'm just saying well i
was into him so i wanted him to meet my
friends
but do you remember the joke your friend
told about the helmet
looking at me disrespectful what girl
what what was that do you remember your
friend was there that talking about
helmets
because you were working on it you were
working on your like town hall [ __ ] at
the time
and you were like should i say it all
the way should i say riri and he was
like yo
i almost peed on myself that's how hard
i was laughing at
that you were coming up with us i don't
remember trying to think who was with us
alex left we went to max fish some some
people that built your furniture
and one guy that doesn't ben oh and mike
mike montgomery that doesn't stop
talking he's the sweetest kid in the
world
mike we love you man stop stop slamming
mom we got mike yo we here to slander
you
all right um 100 lies and deflections
100 uh look guys we got to wrap up this
podcast
anything else you would like to say
queen no
you should always have the last word
taylor black queen at least
he's spoken louise why you can't let her
talk why are you guys
[ __ ] taylor anything you'd like to say
uninterrupted
no that's it she you silenced her you
happy about that
disenfranchiser from this podcast
unbelievable try to make herself the
princess
oh i didn't name myself that
she could me the princess i'll be the
queen oh [ __ ] oh
[Applause]
[ __ ]
you